something that i'm really impressed by
both of you
is that you both became like sort of
famous at a very young age
but managed to keep your career going
and to like sort of not
get off the path that other people have
fallen to
and i'm curious who do you each for each
of you who do you credit
for sort of keeping you like on the
right path and maintaining your career
for for such a long time i don't know
about juliet but i'll give you a quick
answer which i think i don't know
i i will say this i didn't move to la i
wasn't a transplant and i didn't come
here when i was 18 to make it
so my life was always in la so my
friends
or my friends from school and i became
an actor at a young age but i loved it
but my parents were like that's cool
you still got to go to school so my
parents still made me go to public
school
and then like i would do something
horrible they would ground me and i was
like well how did somebody get to work
in the morning and they were like here's
money for the bus
figure it out so i
probably have to say that my parents and
their lack of not giving a [ __ ]
um is a huge testament to why i think i
looked at this as like a mirror like i
love what i do
but it doesn't mean that that is who i
am as to how i was able to separate the
two
also i think neither one of us came up
in a world of um social media and so i
think that because of that it changed i
think the second that perez hilton
spiked on the internet and became like
tabloid fodder before it was like weekly
at most you'd have like your us
weeklies or people or whatever it was
and then it became daily
then it became hourly then it became by
the minute then it became
in real time and it was an impossible
task
you can't be a human being and not
fail in front of people and we're now
living in a canceled culture where i
feel so bad
for every single young actor who's
trying to make it because
you you you're just allowing yourself
you're leaving yourself to be so
vulnerable to so many people that you
can't control the opinion of
my long-winded way of saying i got lucky
that it happened during a period of time
when the internet existed
but wasn't what it is today yeah i think
i mean i can
second some of this in that our
upbringing my parents
are so they're both artists my dad
was a character actor so i was on movie
sets when i was younger so i always knew
it as a line of work
for the the the freaks and the
alternative people and
people who live in their imagination so
i i
but i knew it very much as a line of
work so i didn't
both of us we didn't it wasn't magazine
culture
and then um it wasn't to be famous right
like you can say like it wasn't you
didn't act because you wanted to be
famous yeah i think that it becomes
of a little bit of a fine line nowadays
i think people want to be famous so they
become actors
uh totally different yeah for me it's
like a you know a hunger request because
you have something to say and you want
to live in other people's skin
um i did have a little imploding when i
was
19 20. i was an introvert and i didn't
know how to uh
articulate myself yet but now i'm in my
40s and i'm you know
loud and proud and all that good stuff